bitte schön danke schön ein Geschenk von
Hamza welch eine Seltenheit
[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben willkommen zu einem
neuen Video bei dem ich ein Starbucks
Rezept Nachmache weil der Carrot Cake so
gut bei euch ankam hat haben sie mir
direkt den nächsten Kuchen geholt drei
Jahre her ne ja super aber wir nehmen
wieder Fahrt auf und ich gucke jetzt
noch was haben sie mitgebracht hat und
was ich heute nachmachen darf oh das ist
der chocolate cake das ist dieser
unfassbar schokoladige Kuchen der immer
in super schmales Stückchen geschnitten
ist kann das auch annehmen ja das sind
schon immer so so unfassbar schmale
Stückchen muss ich echt sagen
ich wollte gerade sagen gerade ähm also
wenn man den zu Hause selber macht kann
man hier natürlich auch in breitere
Stücke schneiden es kann auch sein dass
es so Schokolade und süß ist das ähm ja
einfach so ein schmale Stück dann total
angebracht ist es besteht aus ähm zwei
saftigen schokoböden und obendrüber ist
auch noch mal Schoko Boden quasi als
Hügel drauf gegeben ich finde das eine
Optik mega hübsch nebenbei bemerkt und
Schokoladen Arsch
da gehe ich jetzt mal Türen dann machen
wir gleich weiter das war eine home one
so ich habe mir Gedanken gemacht und
eigentlich total blöd weil der Kuchen
besteht ja aus zwei saftigen schokoböden
plus noch mal diese dicke Bodenschicht
oben drüber die einfach auch die Optik
macht das ist ja dann quasi wie eine
dritte Schicht also habe ich jetzt zwei
Tortenringe plus noch einen dritten für
diese Schokostückchen ist total blöd vor
allem abgesehen davon weiß ich nicht ob
ihr jetzt wirklich drei Tortenringe zu
Hause habt das heißt ihr backt viele
macht das natürlich Sinn dann erst kam
ich auf die Idee Moment
bin ich da nicht vorher drauf gekommen
ich mache das ganze in einer in einem
Backrahmen also eckig und steche dann
die runden Böden aus und werde dann aus
dem Rest der ja dann entsteht weil wir
Runde Böden hier ausstechen daraus mache
ich dann die
wie heiße gar nichts mehr ich check gar
nichts mehr ich bin noch zum Film jetzt
hier essen also ihr habt bestimmt
verstanden was ich meine weil die Kiki
Unity die Backe auch sehr gerne
also ich finde es war wirklich spaß
beiseite aber so ein Backrahmen macht
eigentlich immer Sinn ich habe jetzt
hier auch ähm unten drunter mein
gelochtes Blech also das ist schön
gerade ist und ich auch nicht so mal
Stellen habt ihr total durchgebacken und
trocken sind und dann wieder umstellen
habe die zu feucht sind und bei so einem
bei so einer Geraden Unterlage habt ihr
eben den Vorteil dass alles gleichmäßig
durchgebacken ist ich habe jetzt schon
mal alle Zutaten für meinen saftigen
Schokoladen zurechtgelegt und abgewogen
und meine hassaufgabe ist eigentlich
immer Kuvertüre zu hacken ich hasse das
also das würde ich das will ich am
liebsten immer abgeben oder ich sollte
einfach Schokodrops benutzen in Zukunft
aber sobald ihr das fein gehackt habt
könnt ihr das schon mal zusammen mit
Butter und es muss viel Butter sein weil
das wird ja ein saftiger Schokokuchen
kommt das zusammen mit Butter hier
einmal in den Topf und da dann den Herd
jetzt nicht auf volle Pulle schalten
weil sonst verbrennt euch die Butter und
dann habt ihr einfach nur ja verbrannte
Butter dann müsste alles nochmal neu
machen sondern auf niedriger Stufe alles
zusammen schmelzen lassen und sobald es
geschmolzen ist noch mal 15 Minuten
abkühlen lassen und dann können wir erst
Eier mit dazu geben weil sonst habt ihr
Rührei und das möchten wir jetzt nicht
im Kuchen
[Musik]
so Zucker kommt jetzt zu den Eiern da
könnt ihr auch schon Vanilleextrakt
dazugeben ich mag es einfach das vorab
zu verrühren damit es sich einfach
perfekt verbindet und die Eigelbe schon
mal so ein bisschen homogener werden
muss jetzt aber nicht so ordentlich sein
aber das kommt jetzt sowieso hier rein
das ist jetzt schön abgekühlt also wenn
ich fühle es ist noch ein ganz ganz ganz
leicht lauwarm das ist okay und jetzt
einmal mit dem Schneebesen die ganze
Zeit rühren und die Eier Zuckermasse
dazugeben und sobald sich das auch
verbunden hat kommen die restlichen
Zutaten dazu das sind jetzt eigentlich
nur noch was haben wir noch schönes Mehl
Backkakao und Backpulver erschrecklich
wenn ihr die Zutaten seht es ist sehr
sehr wenig Mehl aber das bewegt eben
dass der Teig so saftig wird daher traut
euch ruhig und das ganze gebe ich jetzt
aber auch noch durch einen Sieb als er
in die klümchen drin sind oder so gehe
ich das dann einfach damit
[Musik]
tada der Kuchen ist fertig gebacken und
ich zeige euch jetzt mal was wir müssen
nämlich die Stäbchenprobe machen und
dann nehme ich meinen Schaschlikspieße
die braucht jetzt kein teures Tool dafür
ich nehme sogar ein Schaschlikspieße
immer wieder sauber mache und dann öfter
mal verwende so und jetzt seht ihr dass
das also es ist kein feuchter klebriger
Teig mit dran und dann ist er wirklich
perfekt durchgebacken
ja ja ja ja und das lassen wir jetzt
zugede
ckt bestimmt nicht auskühlen und in der
Zwischenzeit machen wir die Ganache für
die Ganache habe ich hier Vollmilch und
Zartbitterkuvertüre
einmal rein damit dann habe ich hier auf
dem Herd schon mal Sahne
wie du das reingetan hast diese beiden
Sorten Schokolade ist immer da kommt
jetzt einmal zur Sahne Glukose Sirup
keine Sorge wenn ihr keinen Glukosesirup
da habt dann braucht ihr das auch nicht
rein und aber es macht die Ganache
einfach noch mal von der Konsistenz her
bisschen geschmeidiger ich schreibe euch
übrigens alle ganz genau Mengenangaben
unten in die Infobox
Part Salz habe ich auch noch weil eine
Prise Salz hebt noch mal den Geschmack
genau und jetzt wird die Sahne einmal
erwärmt ihr merkt das dann auch daran
dass es so ganz kleine Bläschen
entstehen nicht hoch kochen also sollte
jetzt nicht blubbern sondern wirklich
einfach nur erwärmen und dann gießt ihr
das auf die Schokolade macht den Deckel
drauf wartet fünf Minuten weil das dann
schon so ein bisschen anschmelzen kann
und anschließen wir das komplett einmal
durchgerührt damit so eine richtig
schöne schok omasse entsteht die muss
dann halt allerdings Auskühlen daher
habt ihr dann so ein bisschen
Entspannung und können in der
Zwischenzeit die Küche aufräumen und
euer Partner kann euch dabei helfen
immer
[Musik]
die Ganache hatte ich jetzt bei mir im
Tiefkühlfach ihr habt ja gerade gesehen
dass sie sehr flüssig war und ihr fester
sie wird umso cremiger wird sie auch
also sie ist eigentlich von der
Konsistenz her ja wie unsere cream würde
ich fast schon sagen also wie ein
Aufstrich und das könnt ihr nur also die
Konsistenz könnt ihr nur bekommen wenn
ihr es wirklich kühlt und nicht jetzt
auf Zimmertemperatur stehen lassen ich
persönlich habe ja wie gesagt Platz im
Gefrierschrank gemacht damit es
schneller geht das hat jetzt ungefähr 45
Minuten gedauert wenn ihr Zeit habt
könnt ihr das auch einfach in den
Kühlschrank stellen und immer wieder
zwischendurch umrühren und hier ist
unser saftiger Schoko Boden den werden
wir jetzt ausstechen dafür werde ich
jetzt erstmal den Backrahmen entfernen
damit ich mir die Ränder jetzt nicht
wegreise einmal mit dem backformlöser
rangehen und dann stellt sich mir das
einfach auf so eine eckige Tortenplatte
dann könnt ihr dann wie gesagt einfach
mit dem Tortenring oder mit irgendeinem
runden utensilbermann Tortenring eignet
sich das schon echt am besten einfach
die Böden ausstechen die sind jetzt auch
von der Höhe her müssen mal gucken ich
sehe hier an der Skala das ist ca
2,5 cm oder fast drei ja die Höhe ist
perfekt sehr schön ich liebe es wenn der
Plan aufgeht so dann einmal hier runter
nehmen am besten schiebt ihr das auch
schon direkt vom Backpapier runter dann
habt ihr das lästige Backpapier nicht
mehr da aber ist das erstmal so runter
das kommt weg
so und jetzt einmal vom Backpapier
runterziehen dann geht ihr mit dem
cakeboard einfach ganz vorsichtig runter
schiebt das einmal nach vorne
zack fertig ich stelle jetzt einmal
können auch vorher markieren dass sie
auch ganz sicher 2 Runde Böden erhalten
ja das kommt hin habe ich auf 20 cm
eingestellt
stechen
ja auch und den Rest könnt ihr euch dann
gleich zurechtschneiden für die dritte
Schicht quasi so wenn es dann stapeln
geht könnt ihr euch quasi aussuchen
nehmt jetzt ein Tortenring das ist schön
gerade ist oder stapelt ihr das einfach
so frei nach Schnauze ich zeige euch das
jetzt einfach mal ohne Tortenringe
beleidigt fühlen bitte also ich fand das
ist echt so damit äh ohne Tore damit ihr
sehen könnt ähm wie viel Creme da jetzt
also danach ungefähr drauf kommt immer
mal wieder rühren ich merke auch gerade
dass durch die restkälte das immer
fester wird und wenn ihr rührt könnt ihr
das umgehen und das wird schön
geschmeidig so und bei Starbucks muss
ich sagen sind die Ganache Schichten
wir sind jetzt nicht gerade dünn oder
es geht ne also Mittelding finde ich
also ich glaube jeder der Schokolade
liebt wird auch diese Torte lieben das
ist ja echt schokoporner wie oft habe
ich schon gefragt kannst du bitte das
Rezept nachmachen
bist du dann einfach dahin gegangen bist
so eine coppen diese Torte kaufen
die letzten Jahren die einfach
nachmachen
noch einmal kaufen
auseinandernehmen und speziell
ja sicher man geht auf mein Nacken so
ich denke so ist echt okay oder ein
bisschen mehr so im Anschnitt ja auch
schon ne das sollte ja auch identisch
aussehen so und da kommt jetzt einfach
der nächste Boden oben drauf dann noch
mal die gleiche Menge an Ganache und
dann bröseln wir diese Kuchenstücke noch
dazu ja nicht bröseln sondern wir
schneiden sie zu großen Rauten oder
Viereck oder sowas und dann ist es auch
schon fast fertig das Rezept
[Musik]
meine Torte weiß noch 10 Minuten lang im
Tiefkühler wenn ihr kein Platz im
Tiefkühler habt dann bitte noch mal für
30 Minuten in den Kühlschrank stellen
ich habe die Ganache über dem Wasserbad
die ganz kurz erwärmt dass dort nur
wenige Sekunden und dann ist sie wieder
so dickflüssig und das wird jetzt einmal
komplett auf die Torte gegossen ich habe
außen herum überall noch
backpapierschutz gemacht mit der
Hoffnung dass ich die Küche nicht so ein
sauer und jetzt kommt es das freie
Moment
oh Gott oh es ist echt das ist wie auch
so Werbung also verboten verboten lecker
sieht das aus und sieht heftig aus jetzt
würde ich aber instinktiv so ein paar
Mal klopfen weil ich will ja dass man
die Kuchenstücke oben auch erkennt
und das erinnert mich ein bisschen
Sebastian
also ein bisschen Aggression raus
genau und man merkt auch wenn man klopft
guck mal dann sieht man diese schönen
Brocken das macht jetzt so lange bis ihr
sie wirklich vollständig seht und dann
den Rand einfach nur noch glatt
streichen dann müsste sie gekühlt werden
fertig
[Musik]
alles gut es ist in Ordnung ich weiß ich
habe letzte Sequenz den Ton verkackt als
das meine Schuld aber aber ein altes
Ritual gesagt immer wenn der Ton scheiße
ist
geht das Video immer ganz gut steil ja
so dann wollen wir mal probieren in jede
Schicht einmal haben wir ne vor mir boah
das hätte ich an meinen Nahaufnahme
zeigen dass man gleitet so gut durch mit
der Gabel
ich kann es jetzt zeigen
der schmeckt ultra schokoladig also ich
sag ich sag mal so ich bin voll der
Schokofan und daher liebe ich diesen
Kuchen
ja arbeite ich mit der frischer
und das ist so eine Mischung aus Herz
und süß also es ist nicht nur ihr weiß
nicht nur auf Zucker Zucker Zucker
sondern dadurch dass wir
Zartbitterschokolade haben ist es auch
noch so herb also richtig angenehm
richtig schokoladig einfach
immer leckerer als normal dann müssen
wir auch sauber ist nicht schlecht reden
und mega Schokolade
machen unbedingt unbedingt
so 24 Stückchen oder so rechnen weil die
ja dann auch so
ne das ist eine doppelte dreifache
Portion aber es schmeckt echt heftig
also wirklich ich weiß nicht ob einer
der oder sogar der leckerste
Schokokuchen ist den ich überhaupt je
gemacht habe auf meinem Kanal also das
ist mega krass
hammermäßig sehr lecker also Leute
abonnieren liken like mal das Video auch
wenn ihr jetzt sieht wirklich liken ne
ich gucke jetzt einfach weiter und gucke
das nächste Video nein like das Video
jetzt dort meine Sekunde und es hilft
unserem Kanal echt sehr weiterhin
Rezepte machen
genau und dann ja sehen wir uns auch
beim nächsten Mal
[Musik]